[Music]
foreign
what's going on guys uh we we are back
at it again with uh
you know another week of r r with the
Lord's got me and King here you know we
got we got a pretty uh sizable show for
you guys today you know we're gonna be
talking about uh cocaine bear this uh
Netflix movie that King had me watch
called we have a ghost and we got two
episodes The Last of Us to catch up on
uh so first off let's let's go to the
Navy and greedy stuff man what what
you've been watching this kid I mean uh
King
yeah
um
all right besides the stuff that we have
on Deck uh I've been doing a whole lot
of Channel searching and uh stuff that
I'm trying to catch up on like I saw the
last season of Picard is uh going up so
I'm I'm a huge Star Trek dude and it's
very rare that you have a person that
likes Star Trek and like Star Wars in
the same insane breath actually it's not
that I'm against Star Trek I I haven't
really seen it enough to
to give it a fair shot does that make
sense
yeah hey
um me as a kid you know um all right so
I'm old enough to know when the TV turns
off right so we used to have like only
like three or four channels three or
four channels like ABC CBS uh ABC CBS
NBC
and
that was it I think
and and I don't know and then after that
you got Fox and some other stuff started
popping up but okay so at a certain time
the TV turns off and it's the American
flag
shown
so
up until that point the last uh shows
that will be on late night you said like
around 10 and 11 o'clock was Star Trek
and then you know chillers so whenever
you see the hand come out the ground
that's chill is you out of that as you
know your kid you're going to be
terrified but I would watch Star Trek
you know as I'm falling asleep and
um Captain Kirk was like my hero as a
kid so I I know every episode I know
from the beginning to the end and then
from them I love just you know kept
going like when it started coming out
with motion pitches like you know Wrath
of Khan and stuff like that so and then
they did the reboot so I'm a full-on
Star Trek dude but at the same time I
was there from the Genesis of Star Wars
so I'm a full-on Star Wars dude but not
like you know these dudes that's out
there fighting with lightsabers in the
street and stuff like that you just like
the universe it's a very yeah I love
freaking Universe to you I think I'm the
same way when it comes to stuff like
that you know I think the universe is
fascinating but you know there's a lot
of things that I feel like they could do
better
and I think we have this like bad
concept now where people want to do
stuff as fast as possible they want to
build up to anything yeah I feel like
these days the only companies that's
really gave that type of approach uh an
option is something like Marvel and
what's funny is they're owned by the
same person Disney
uh so you know I'm just curious on how
that goes
um I think we have the Mandalorian here
soon so it's coming up interesting and
and I watched the bad batch bad batches
of cartoons uh series based on the Clone
Wars where there's a renegade
um uh group of uh and they they like to
say ragtag group I just more like you
say Renegade uh clones that were
probably defective so that's why they
got the name the bad batch and uh
they're comprised of uh a four to five
uh
uh clones that are formed a group and
they tell a story and right now I'm
doing it with uh the Lord's minute so
you can catch that you know when we post
it to website uh lordsgaming.net and you
know those episodes is really fun so
they just came to the conclusion and we
just uh recorded the last two episodes
of that so that was fun
yes what's up um I finished chainsaw man
oh uh that I I just because I've just
been doing so much I haven't had time to
sit down and really dive into a reaction
but last night couldn't sleep my mama
just finished all of this and I watched
like nine episodes straight uh but uh I
got two of the reactions yeah they're
all recorded uh I got two reactions
right now because I know last week we
was kind of light with the reaction so I
put two up today uh both of them are on
um our patreon so definitely uh it's the
description if you want to go check out
my reaction to that I think I did
episode five and six that's what's up
right now that show that show's crazy
man because I finished the whole first
season okay and
um
this is one of the few animes because
there's always like sexual tension and a
lot of animes but this is one of the
first animes I've seen to explore it you
know what I'm saying like it feels like
everybody thirsty on there everybody
wants to Bone everybody else like but
they like they that they only really do
that when there's nothing serious going
on but when it gets serious they get
serious you know where can I find that
at it's not it's on uh uh
um
the whole first season yes it is dubbed
that's the the thing that we reacted to
it's a really interesting thing man it's
really interesting I actually watched it
uh you know five six seven eight nine
ten eleven to twelve last night wow and
you know it was a lot easier because
once I got to a certain point I was like
okay this this is crazy
you know pretty much what the show's
about is
you got demons
have took over the world just about like
look there's still a structure and
humans still exist but don't get a Twist
the demons are causing Havoc all around
you know what I'm saying and it's it's
modern society like what we are now but
they have hired devil Hunters uh in
pretty much uh what happens is
an individual could sign a pack with a
devil
okay and so but they have to they have
to sacrifice something to maintain their
power uh so there there's a uh there's a
a woman on there that she made a pact
with a ghost devil where she can she
gave the ghost over her eye
but she could control the ghost Devil's
right arm
so pretty much what but the thing is is
when she fights the people she fights
can't touch the ghost because it's a
ghost right so it's pretty much they're
fighting something they can't fight back
with you know what I'm saying she's just
beating the hell out of him with that
Ghost Armor yeah yeah and then the main
character he he made a pact with a
chainsaw devil okay and he turns into uh
like his arms become chainsaws and his
head gets a giant chainsaw on his head
and uh it's an interesting thing I think
they could have did a little bit better
on um some of the World building but
what I will say is this
this animate does a very good job of
making you care about these individuals
because once stuff starts flying off I
felt a whip like damn
like that didn't just happen man I was
in like a little a little bit of denial
man a little bit of denial
but yeah um
I there's a couple people already making
suggestions for the uh for my next
reaction I will get back to you guys
eventually when I figure out what it's
going to be uh but you know right now
we're gonna go ahead and move into the
first topic uh you know it's it's it's
cocaine bear man cocaine bear it came
out on what so you know cocaine bear
came out on movies though the funny
thing is my particular
my particular movie theater even before
they closed down they didn't even have
it like it was it was kind of funny and
I think the reason they didn't have it
is because what's the point in doing
that when you're about to go out of
business so yeah I think it's not going
to happen that's probably the biggest
reason they didn't have it but you know
King tell us a little bit about cocaine
bear like is it worth going and watching
all right so
let me let me tell you how I came across
it right so is this popular uh guy
that's on Tick Tock I found them on Tick
Tock his name is Mr Ballin right and he
tells
strange and mysterious stories in in
story form you know and I came across
them on Tick Tock and then I found out
he had a YouTube channel and I went to
his YouTube channel and he's he was an
ex-marine and this is why I say in life
you never know exactly what your true
calling is when you hear this guy speak
he tells such a great story that you're
in trance with whatever the story may be
so he was telling the story of cocaine
bear and the story that he told was
pretty mundane but he said it's going to
be a major major motion picture uh
coming out next year so I heard this
last year
fast forward to now I saw the trailer
for cocaine bear
and I said oh my God
that looks hilarious now the real story
was a little bit Monday
this trailer takes it and pushes it to
the Limit right so it's set in 1985 and
everything is 1985 you have posters on
the wall of Adam Ant he was a popular
um music artist that I really like
myself and uh you have Ray Liotta that's
in the film yeah uh Ice Cube son that's
in the film film
you had a lot of actors some some
well-known actors and you know some not
so known actors but it takes it back to
the year 1985. the feel of 1985. like
how movies was made in 1985 where the
1985 sensibility like where we weren't
always offended with certain things like
everything right now is either they're
pushing an agenda or somebody's too
sensitive and you don't want to step on
anybody's toes this movie throws all of
that out the window like they don't care
who they offend they don't care how
sensitive you are they don't care about
pushing any agendas they care about
telling probably the most outrageous
funniest uh Niche movie that's going to
be a cult classic I I predict it right
now this is a cult classic movie that
has come out and is going to take the
World by storm I I dare anybody to go
see this film and don't walk out the
movie theater either laughing cry
laughing or calling your friends telling
them get up and go see this movie now
it's worth your money
it was better than Ant-Man
um
way better than that man if if you have
a choice and you're walking in the movie
theater and you're an adult and I and I
say this
an adult because this is an adult film
choose cocaine bear
trust me you're not gonna be upset it's
okay so
the host premises is just piling on the
plane and he finds out that the FBI is
following him and he starts dumping all
these pounds of cocaine in satchels they
have red satchels and he's throwing them
out the plane in the middle of the night
and then he goes to jump out the plane
hits his head and dies right because the
bear gets one of those cocaine pallets
oh well
it's littered through all of Chappaqua
mountains
and
they they have statues all over the
place there's there's duffel bags full
of this stuff all over the place
the little kids are going and cutting
school and they come across a bear
now the bear don't look like a normal
bear
he looks a little erratic like
something's up with this bear
but these little kids find uh
um a kilo of uh of uncut stuff and they
start to experiment with the stuff
that's there
well the beer doesn't care too much
about them the bear cares about the
stuff that they're experimenting with
and the bear goes for that and chases
them so that's how the story starts
about a mother trying to find her kid
and her hello her friend the the little
boy that cut school well there's a
police officer that knows that
that because the FBI was chasing these
dudes knows that there's uh statues up
in the mountains he's going to recover
it he's trying to lock up the the head
guy that's in charge of all of this
that's Ray Liotta and which is really
funny because he has Prosthetics on his
face which is really nuts and Ray Liotta
sends his his henchmen and his son well
his henchman and his son to go retrieve
all the statues
they're going up to this mountain well
in this mountain area is a small town
where you have a couple of people that
lived there a couple of you know
characters
this beer proceeds to run ripshaw all
over it's like Jason on cocaine right so
imagine uh uh uh 800 pound gorilla 500
pound gorilla I mean um bear running all
over the place high as hell
attacking people
with no Rhyme or Reason but all he wants
to do is get to the cocaine
now there's a plot twist involved there
is funny banter all the way through and
the story is concise from beginning to
end it tells a great story
it tells a real poignant story and the
people talk like normal people like in
certain instances with certain things
happen they react like real people so
it's it's if you're into slasher films
if you need it you know it's funny King
you don't know it but they uh they they
actually put these actors on a mountain
and put a real cocaine bear and gave him
cocaine and that's why everything's
census
they're like oh God there's a real bear
your attic is a part in the movie
where you think the bear is out he like
damn man he got the big because you
start rooting for the bear at some point
right like damn man they got the beer
and a bag a kilo of cocaine pops open
and it hits his nose and he sniffs it
out all out the air
and he wakes up like going to the day
it is the most hilarious thing that you
will get to see and you know I really
wanted you to see it because it is a
slasher film and I know you're into
slasher films but most of all I know you
like a real good movie a good comedy I
don't know like I've kind of like laid
back off comedies in the past few years
like yeah you know I I stick to like
mainly the old I like like suspension
like serious tone movies these days uh
but you know I think this is something I
would try uh you know right now
obviously well I think because they they
have like a like a mom-and-pop theater
here that I wasn't aware of and
obviously once AMC went down you know
then people was on Facebook oh you can
come down here
so now apparently they got like some
kind of uh Stafford loan or something
like that and they're building more more
uh more rooms because they only had one
like showing room oh well that's crazy
yeah because it was like a mom and pop
stuff so it it's interesting I I'm
willing to give it a try when it
actually I think the fourth is when the
next showing so that's in like four days
uh so you know I I that's that's going
to be an interesting thing I might you
know put out a review on uh on patreon
or something like that or in the YouTube
channel probably put it on patreon for
like a month and then put it on the
YouTube channel uh the r r YouTube
channel I'm I'm definitely giving a five
five popcorn five popcorn five popcorn I
think that's the first thing you've gave
to No No No I gave five to uh uh
episodes of The Last of Us okay you know
what she gave a five two two what to
that to the Ant-Man
but I just they did certain things that
you know did you see that video I sent
you where uh it was it was like I don't
understand why she reopened the portal
she didn't know if Ant-Man won that
fight or not so she just opened it to
let him come back in if if what's funny
is if wasp would and then people in the
comment section they did they thought
Kang was dead then why'd wasp go back
through yeah like they knew Kane was
alive that's a cat like he's you know
what I find stupid about the whole thing
well she's the reason why the whole
thing started so that's one but think
about it like this if you if if if
Jane Van Dam uh was trapped down there
for 30 years
and
she knew about Kane down there and she
gets back and this guy Scott is uh
well you know Ant-Man is an Avenger
you're not going to tell him and warn
him exactly what you know and what
you've seen down there
but you're gonna keep that hush
it it made it seem like they didn't know
what the movie was gonna be at first
like that that it kind of seemed like
back then when they were making those
ant-mans they didn't know who was gonna
be the next villain you know what I'm
saying it was kind of like shoehorned in
there at the last moment I guess maybe
because they thought they was probably
gonna have to do Dr Doom and they didn't
know if the fox deal was going to go
through to do the Fantastic Four and
whatever and how to set it up and I
think King was the next logical logical
uh character that they could use you
know um because he is a big bad he's
like a big threat that's why I send you
you know a ton of information on them
but I know that information didn't do
you any good especially when Marvel did
or Disney didn't use him to that full
potential that you saw
and you know um shout out to lock he
told me he's like look like you know he
he wasn't at full power he just had a
suit that's all he didn't really have
any of the gimmicks that makes him him
and I'm like that's not my fault though
that's Marvel's fault like exactly they
you know and I get it they showed an
individual uh just an opening on him but
it's just like to me I expected
something on par or better than when
they shut down it's not that is we won't
really go into that if you guys want to
see more of that information spoiler
class last week we talked about uh
Ant-Man I think you guys will enjoy that
but we're I guess I guess I guess it's
time to move on to